the division last year it could have
been written off as a tech demo it was
sort of an unknown quantity you were
showing off the tech as much as you were
showing off the gameplay it seems and so
it seemed like there was a lot of
pressure on you guys to sort of either
show something that's similar or better
and what we saw I think probably made
people feel a lot more comfortable about
what they thought the division was it
seems to be in line with watching guys
her last year yeah I mean I think it's
always really challenging to create a
demo for these shows in an open-world
game that you're you're pushing for you
know long-term engagement with your
players you're pushing for you know
investment in the game and then show us
all of that all wrapped in an RPG you
know shell show us all of that in four
and a half minutes so it's I love the
demo I think it's it does a great job of
really hinting at some new gameplay
features that were bringing this year as
well as reinforcing the fact of you know
this is the game that everyone got
excited for this is the game that we're
building and that's what we're we have
remained on track in the last year since
she saw us awesome so let's talk about
gameplay mechanics that's I think what
everyone wants to get into this okay
Deanna and it looks to me like the
division is more of an RPG than a
shooter is that fair to say absolutely
absolutely I would say we're you know
that's probably one of the bigger
misconceptions about the game is that
it's a third-person shooter you know
we're Clancy game guns are important in
in the game there's but for us it's more
of the categories of guns so you have
pistols SMGs assault rifles marksman
rifles and shotguns and those are like
classifications kind of archetypes of
women's rather than you know throwing
thousands and thousands of guns at you
there's a purpose for the gun choice and
the synergies with the skill choice is
the the RPG angle and the importance of
the weapon and so the character you play
as and it's not the same character for
everyone in this game or they're going
to create their own character because
the sort of the group of folks that you
have it seems is it the same group as
you have that was on purpose because we
wanted to continue the story you know
last year it was dude check out
Manhattan yeah and then this year we're
in man
with Megan and Bronson and we and player
one so the but absolutely character
customization and creation is important
I think in RPGs it's your first
connection with your your avatar your
your connection to this world and so
being able to put your own personal
touch are you male or your female skin
tone you know background that is
important okay so we're looking at the
demo here yes and let's give a little
tweak there yeah well yeah we're you
just talk us through what's going on
here maybe talk about some stuff that we
might have seen so this is uh oh now I'm
totally dead are we good yeah sorry I
was eating my mic guys so this is what
we call echo it's a new investigation
tool for the agents so we're constantly
collecting digital information from the
environment and if certain locations uh
echo we'll be able to create these 3d
scenes reconstructing either
closed-circuit cameras cell phone
conversations environmental clues and in
this case we completed a missing-persons
missions but it could be story elements
could be hidden locations that you don't
see that are now clarified so it's it's
our cutscenes if you will that work in
an open-world multiplayer game so if you
start an echo scene I can see it I can
get hints or clues from it and
vice-versa and you can sort of engage it
and get XP or you can just kind of leave
it aside and you'll need to kind of move
through them and hunt it's not a
something that plays for you there
frozen moments in time so here's where
we saw another engagement like similar
to what we saw last year yes but there
were some differences it seems like you
guys have leaned into the RPG sub with
having hit numbers and whatnot come on
scrolling combat text last year but it's
it's important I think especially when
you have a game where quality of items
and damage types matter and your
distances matter you need to see you
know the the effect of that so critical
hits the amount of damage you're doing
is displayed out and when a reminder
folks are going to have any questions at
all to send them in at Danny O'Dwyer on
Twitter and I'll make my I'll do my best
to try and pull them out and I'll
can we talk I want to talk about um
single-player yeah this game just from
an overall view I feel like some people
aren't too sure about where the coop
starts where the online element starts
and is there a single-player part so you
just give a sort of a basic overview of
okay at all they have the division works
we first put it in your console okay I
mean the division itself is an online
game but it doesn't mean that you are
you're forced to play with other players
so you could buy the game play through
the entire campaign and take back New
York experience all the content get to
maximum level and never engage with
another human being if you don't want to
but the way we set it up we really want
to encourage multiplayer we we rewarded
obviously with experience with currency
in the game it's we believe the best way
to play the game is to play with others
and then if you go into areas where
there's player versus player you're
probably we're gonna want to have
somebody to have your back a little bit
okay it's kind of fodder and so when
you're walking around in this world is
what is a maximum amount of other
players that we could be in your your
game as you're playing in the open world
that's faced so your group is what
you'll see but so it's kind of like a an
instance in New York but it's and it's
different but that's a good way to visit
to it's a touchstone to people
understand yeah and but then there's
public areas like the last kind of
stronghold or foothills we have in the
area for the friendly faction in the
game it's a public hub and then the dark
zones that we have in the game are there
areas where you'd be bumping into people
you don't know or is this very much an
opt-in situation is opt-in so you'll
know when you go into an area where you
could potentially run into other players
but would it be a player that you knew
that you were friends with or could it
be someone right could be okay because I
think that's a for instance watchdogs
when we first saw about it looked like
the engagements and the hacking stuff
might happen sort of a little bit less
live with a little bit less of your
control but it actually seems to be much
more of a controlled experience so there
is an element of random interaction in
the division but just in specific areas
yes so I think I'm not sure how fun that
might be if you're just kind of
you know opt it in on but you know the
game is about choice we really push that
with the map that you saw in the demos
with how we kind of encourage you to
experience the content in the game you
want it we don't want to be leading the
player around New York we want that to
be a choice so when you go into an area
that those kind of things can happen you
will definitely know and it will be a
choice it's reminded me a bit of Hell
Gate London actually in that respect
yeah Joel Adam pally on Twitter's asking
how does the death mechanic work in
terms of respawning and losing gear and
stuff like that yeah it's a it's a great
question that's something that you know
the team and we have massive continue to
iterate upon so respawn mechanics is
basically probably what is asking about
is something that you kind of hone up
until the end it's okay you want death
to be punishing we want it to be
punishing in the game about to punishing
so that it's it's it keeps people from
playing you know what makes someone that
drop it so you definitely respawn in the
game and where we look at where that
location is but details of you know
durability loss and all that you know
that's still in flux okay and Brett
cadeaux asks and is the cards are all
the car doors able to be closing so
that's in every single card or in the
gameplay we just showed there's a part
where one of the players runs up and
hits it like are you doing this
intentionally or 2.0 that so that's our
realization director Tobias Newman threw
that in there is a big fan of that but
yes we had to have a card or at some
point but no I mean on a serious note
environmental interactions or
environmental animations and we will are
important I think it's great for the
game they're great for immersion so you
will have them but I can say that not
every card or
at this trailer you released a CG
trailers I'm often not a fan of but I
thought this was absolutely incredible
and sort of a you're sort of alluding to
earlier as well this it's sort of a
dangerous trailer because for a triple-a
game it's actually quite moody
understated and there's not much crazy
action going on yeah is this something
that you guys are kind of aware of where
you know you're trying to ensure that
you get the mainstream you know
attention by having a game that's that
has shooting in it and is it has
elements of touchstone to people contend
mainstream gamers can take but then are
you really trying to make something
that's particularly not like that is
actually a bit more rich in and moody
and involved yeah I think we are an
action RPG so you know there is going to
be a lot of fighting and combat in the
game it's but what are you doing that
for what is your connection to what
you're saving why are you doing this we
want to introduce the the agents
themselves because again that's another
challenge with an RPG where you're the
hero but we want the division to be kind
of a cognitive thing people know what it
is like what am i what am i part of it's
a division is it the division itself is
it a like a sort of an uprising civilian
uprising or non uprising rather a
civilian almost like a vigilante group
or it's it's a it's a federal unit
that's been trained for CBRN which is
super non sexy but yes it's chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
training so to respond to these type of
events so it's a new Tom Clancy unit
that then is activated when this goes
down so it's absolutely not a civilian
unit but they're more civilian that
we're embedded in society
yeah they're only activated if something
like this happens who's that who's the
primary antagonist in this then is it is
it groups within the world that are
trying to take over what's left of New
York or that you'll find out when you
play oh here we go but yes but
definitely it's a there's a lot of
factions like you see in the CGI we
introduced a couple like the
that you'll see a lot you know the
people taking advantage of of civilians
or the sick in the city and then the
last guys the guys with flamethrowers
the cleaners is our first kind of real
faction introduction wieners the
cleaners is terrifying yes I stopped off
there roaming New York they're attracted
to levels of high contagion and they're
definitely group oriented so you're not
going to want to take them on when you
run around by yourself and there are
roaming faction so you could potentially
run into them all over New York so
outside of the campaign you've said
there are PvP areas there are sort of
safe zones where you might run into
other players as well and then there's
the the single-player campaign which can
be played I guess either on your own or
with hopefully the multiplayer sorry the
money is so outside of that the the
straight edge campaign this is what
you're doing and is it is it is it quite
linear or are you given a wide area of a
map and you're sort of let your own
devices yeah you're absolutely given a
you get a readout you get a choice the
the map is really really critical in the
game I we're really pushing I believe as
much information as you can on the app
so that it's almost like a menu what's
happening what do I want to choose what
do I want to go and so but there is New
York it's an RPG so New York is does
have a progression to it so there might
be places that you can go but you should
yeah you won't have as much success if
you venture there I'm having absolutely
loads of questions especially for more
PG fans all right Queen asks a really
good one and what kinds of things will
your character have to watch out for
beside enemies so are you guys leaning
it to stuff in terms of food drink rest
or items that you might need sure it's a
great question we we get a lot of
feedback add massive on our forums and
everything about the survival aspect
with the division and then we know
there's a lot of interest for that we
hear it
we-we-we under we're looking into how we
can address that but for the game itself
what we wanted to do with food and water
is take that mechanic that's pretty
harsh in a lot of other games yeah and
make it a positive so they're important
in the game food and water and resources
but there are only a
so if you don't have them you don't die
or starve to death
which is a very punishing mechanic in
games Oh last question before you go
Ryan I want to ask you at the division
that seems like that game almost like I
feel like watchdogs was at one stage
which perhaps didn't deliver and that
it's it's one of those games that people
think is that the true next-gen
experience is the division a type of
game that could not have been done on
previous generation consoles and what is
it about this new level of parody that
allows you to make this game yeah I
think it's a great question I think that
the game could have been done obviously
on previous generations of consoles but
nowhere near the level of detail that we
can get to nowhere near the the
animation level the immersion that we
can create for the players and and to
plug our engine which is awesome the
snowdrop engine i mean it's being
developed for this game so things that
we need because we need some paint cans
that we can do secondaries destruction
or we need to brush off some snow and
have that work it's same day that can be
actually in the game so that's really
what has empowered our you know from the
artists to the designers to the to the
tech teams to be able to bring the game
to this level of detail on this scale
perfect right Brad pleasures always game
director on the division thank you so
much for coming on and we got so many
big games coming up on today's stage I
unfortunately have to go and take a
little bit of a break with camera op and
somebody back in a second with friggin
Far Cry 4
stick around here on GameSpot calm